trudeau is a great example of what's
going on here
because he is sort of the perfect
example of what the world economic forum
wants out of a leader they want someone
who stands for nothing who's completely
unable to say the truth but who looks
good on camera who has no real set of
beliefs probably someone who's done
blackface like he has repeatedly because
then they can kind of black
blackmail him when it comes to a couple
things they can blackface him again and
blackmail him on a couple things he's a
really really bad dude in case you don't
know my feelings about him but this is a
great video so rebel news you guys know
rebel news up in canada they are doing
incredible work up there it is not easy
to be an actual place of journalism in
canada and it's getting increasingly
hard
and if you want more on that you should
watch friday's episode the panel show
with ezra levant who started rebel uh
they have a journalist her name is
alexandra lavoy
and she pushed trudeau on what he's
doing related to vax mandates and just
watch this smug
soulless evil freak
news
is
what a coward what a disgusting human
being what an awful world leader and and
someone that should be relegated to the
dustbin
of history she asked an extremely
relevant question it is irrelevant what
he feels about rebel now of course the
reason he doesn't like rebel is because
rebel is an independent news
organization in canada and canada funds
news organizations and then you're not
going to believe it they all basically
give trudeau a pass because the
government is funding the news
organizations that's supposed to be
reporting on the politicians so now he's
got one news organization they're
basically the main one that is outside
of the system so they ask him hard
questions and it wasn't just that it was
a hard question it was a completely
legitimate question hey vaccines aren't
working uh the way they were promised
you have mandated all of this stuff we
basically had an uprising in the country
because of it you were freezing bank
accounts on people you were throwing
people in jail unjustly we know that
it's not working just look what's
happened in israel
could you comment on that and all he
says is no no i won't i don't like you
he is a horrible horrible human being
there's no other way to put it we have
to start just being clear about what
these people are
but here he is just a bit over a year
ago this is a year and a half ago and he
was singing a very very different tune
when it came to canada and vaccine
mandates
in terms of mandatory vaccines vaccines
won't be mandatory that's not the way we
do things in canada oh so that's not the
way we do things in canada that was a
year and a half ago then he did a
complete 180 started jailing people
freezing bank accounts demonizing half
the country calling them racists and
everything else so what happened did did
justin trudeau have some incredible
political evolution or is it possible
that justin trudeau is not really the
prime minister of canada meaning that he
has canadians interests at heart is he
just a foot soldier or a stooge for the
world economic forum and klaus schwab
and his buddy over there
albert the ceo of pfizer basically we're
like hey dude we want everybody to be
injected and you're going to do it and
he takes orders because he's not he's
just a soulless nothing
and of course by the way he shut down
the supply chain when all the truckers
started protesting him then the supply
chain wasn't working uh correctly and
that's sort of exactly what's happening
in the netherlands right now as mark
rute goes after the farmers
but you know what happens in western
societies we've still got a chance
because the individual can still stand
up against the system and david can
always beat goliath i firmly believe
that
the people of canada have had it with
justin trudeau and here he is just a
couple days ago at the calgary stampede
getting
heckled great
a moment to gather and to celebrate
being able to gather once again
he's so inauthentic like you know that
hat has never been worn before his shirt
which is tucked in so perfectly as i say
he's just a suit with nice socks there's
nothing authentic about him and you know
i don't love the idea generally that
people should be getting in the faces of
politicians uh certainly in private
places like restaurants and things like
that but if you want to go to a public
place where they're where they're giving
a speech and yell at them at this point
why not